is humbling and frightening to witness
the ever-changing moves of Mother Nature
is sheer force turning a region known
for its Rich landscape nestled between
Mountains and the Adriatic Sea into a
big swamp
people still trapped in their homes as
the water takes its time to recede
Alexander pironi's family has owned
their house in masalambarda since the
1960s they were among the first
residents on her Street
her husband had put these wooden boards
to prevent the water from seeping in
through the front door
we thought there would be a limited
amount of rain about 10 to 15
centimeters instead it was a much higher
level it's painful we put a lot of
resources into it to renovate to see it
in this state now it's difficult to
watch
many here were trapped on upper floors
one watching the rainwater invade their
streets and homes it's the worst
flooding seen here in about a century
six months of torrential rain fell in a
span of just 36 hours before that the
concern here was drought and the soil
was so dry that when that torrential
downpour came it couldn't absorb it
thousands of Acres of Vineyards food
grows and Vegetable Farms are now
submerged the damage likely to affect
next year's Harvest as well
more than 20 Rivers burst their Banks
sending turrets of Muddy Water tearing
through entire towns like here in
santiagata frightening hours that
sisters Martine and Sandra pianisse
still can't get to terms with
them
it was like having a river here the
current was so strong The Rescuers
couldn't reach us we didn't have food or
water we didn't expect this it's only
the next day at 9pm that The Rescuers
finally came
the pressure of the rising water broke a
wind at the back of the house
and within minutes Furniture was
floating around the level it reached
clearly visible about a meter and a half
it's hard to point fingers under these
circumstances but some are putting at
least some of the blame on Old
infrastructure that couldn't withstand
extreme conditions but mostly people say
is climate change that turns what looks
like a peaceful body of water into a
devastating tidal wave Romania